>>> Ladies and gentlemen, good afternoon.
Would you please welcome to the stage Chris
Yerga.
[ Applause ]
>>Chris Yerga: Thank you very much.
There's actually three of us on stage.
So I'm joined here with my partners in crime
here, Ellie Powers, who's the lead program
manager for the Google Play -- we'll get into
that later, and Miles Barr, who runs the engineering
team.
So I want to talk to you today about Android
Apps in Google Play.
So I'm the engineering director for the Google
Play team.
And it's my job to make sure that every year,
there's more and more opportunities for you
as developers to build a successful business
selling your apps in the Play store.
Now, I want to start by saying thank you.
Thank you for building incredible apps and
games in the Play Store.
Thank you for helping the Google Play store
and the Android platform become the fastest
growing mobile platform around, and thank
you for delighting hundreds of millions of
users with your products.
Mobile apps have gotten to this point where
they've become intertwined in our lives in
a very meaningful way.
And I had actually, you know, written this
intro the other day, and then just a few hours
ago, I had an experience that really underlined
it for me.
I was up on stage.
I had the privilege to be part of the keynote
this morning.
And so I talked a bit about Google Play and
all the great stuff that we are launching
today.
And then I had a moment when I had to step
offstage when Hugo got to announce the Nexus
7 tablet.
So I was sitting on my chair on the side of
the stage and listening to Hugo, and candidly,
we'd rehearsed that presentation numerous
times before, so the content was a little
old to me.
And all of a sudden I discovered, this wasn't
even a conscious thing, I had my phone in
my hand.
And what I was doing was I was playing a game
that I had just downloaded.
So I had recently gone to Japan and got this
insane game, I don't know if anyone is familiar
with it, called Mushroom Garden, where the
game is, you grow mushrooms, it's exactly
what it says on the tin.
There's really nothing more to it.
But it's really oddly compelling.
Because you have to check back to see if you're
getting these rare mushrooms.
I was playing this game and I thought, this
is not a rational thing to be doing.
Like, I'm in the middle of this keynote presentation.
There are 6,000 people in the room.
And I'm playing this game.
But what it reminded me of is the fact that
I think, you know, the best kind of entertainment
or the best kinds of products permeate your
life in that way, where they just become a
part of your behavior, and it's almost like
second thought.
And these applications, they're not just getting
installed into our devices; they're becoming
a part of our lives and our daily existence.
And that, combined with the astounding growth
of Android and the crazy numbers of Android
activations, presents a huge opportunity for
you as developers.
So today we're going to talk about what it
takes to grow your business.
And in order to have a successful business,
there's really, you know, three things that
you need.
First is, obviously, you need customers.
You need people who are coming to your products.
And then you need revenue.
You need some means of monetizing those customers
and turning that into revenue for your business.
And the final thing that you need is data
and insight into how your business is operating
so that you can optimize your business and
the way that you're conducting things to sort
of create this virtuous cycle that will then
folds back to the beginning to help you get
more customers and more revenue.
We're going to be deep-diving into each one
of these areas a bit today.
And let's start off talking about customers.
So in the Google Play team, we really -- we
think about customers on sort of two axes.
So the first one is that, obviously, we want
to be bringing in an ever-increasing number
of customers into the front door of the Google
Play store.
But on the other axis, we also want to be
driving ever-increasing engagement with these
customers.
So what do I mean by that?
So engagement means giving customers more
reasons to come to this store, more reasons
to keep coming back, giving them a delightful
experience when they use the store and make
a purchase so that they're happy, they become
regular customers and trusting in the Google
Play store and are -- we create sort of a
lifelong relationship with them and value.
And if you think about one of the primary
drivers of bringing an ever-increasing number
of customers to the store certainly has to
be the astounding rate of Android device activations.
As we talked about the keynote today, a year
ago, we were at 100 million devices.
Now we're at 400 million total devices activated.
I mean, these are just crazy numbers.
A million devices a day are being activated.
That's a device for every person in the City
of San Francisco, where we're here today,
every single day.
It's just crazy numbers.
And each one of these users is basically a
potential customer of your apps and games.
And the other most meaningful thing that we've
done in the last year is the release of the
Google Play brand.
So to consumers, Google Play means all of
your digital content, apps, games, music,
books, movies, and now magazines and TV, available
across your devices and on the Web.
And so you might, you know, rightly ask yourself,
well, so what does this mean to me as an application
developer?
Well, by bringing all of these content types
together, we did so in a couple ways.
The first is, we put everything under a single
brand, but we also brought all these content
types together in a single store.
And so the more content types that we launch,
the more reasons people have to come to the
store, the more reasons they have to come
back.
And one of the things that we've noticed is
that with each new content type that we launch,
there's additional people who come to the
store and maybe even make their purchase,
their first purchase, from one of these content
types.
So, you know, certainly many people make their
first purchase as an app or game.
But, you know, when we launched music or launched
books, these people come in, they get over
that hump of making their first purchase and
every time they come in the front door of
our store, we're merchandising the full swath
of everything we have, including apps and
games, to them, you're getting an opportunity
to put your products in front of these users.
And the more different types of content that
our users are purchasing, the more engaged
a customer of ours they become.
And so they have more and more reasons to
frequently come back to the store.
And we create a deeper relationship with them.
Now, the other thing that's important about
Google Play is that it's a Google-wide brand.
So by bringing all this stuff together, we
have the opportunity to bring the full weight
of Google's resources behind the store in
a couple different areas.
Promotions, marketing, driving customer awareness,
et cetera.
One simple but pretty concrete example of
this is the fact that we're now present in
the universal navigation bar up here that's
at the top of all of Google's Web properties.
And so this not only gives users sort of a
quick one-click access to the Google Play
store, but what we've also seen is that for
many users, this is driving the first time
they've ever visited the Web Store.
So, you know, we have a lot of people who
use the Device Store on a fairly regular basis.
But this is driving awareness and giving them
yet another opportunity to come to the store,
maybe when they're engaged with their desktop
computer or laptop rather than their mobile
device.
The other thing that's important here is that
by bringing all this content together into
sort of a single umbrella brand, it enables
us to much more effectively do marketing and
promotion.
So when we launched the Google Play brand,
we did this promotion across all the content
types, with deeply discounted content, 25-cent
apps.
It was very successful in not only driving
increased app sales of the things that were
on sale as well as, actually, things that
weren't part of the promotion, but also driving
a higher rate of people making their first
purchase from the Google Play store.
And more recently, we've tried to do some,
you know, more creative things.
Last week, we did this Play with Collectibles
promotion, where we had a variety of in-game
items that were available in the Play Store
for a limited time basis across a variety
of different games.
And I think this is -- we're starting to see
the first sort of creative different ways
that we're trying to experiment with marketing
and promotions here.
You know, I can't really say too much about
our future plans.
But what I'll tell you is this: Google Play
is hugely important for Google.
It's a very strategic thing for us.
We want to -- I mean, we have a great brand.
We have amazing apps and games that you all
have built.
I mean, if you think back to, you know, when
I actually joined the team, just under two
years ago, like, the progress that we've made
in terms of quality of apps and games is just
astounding.
So we have something that's really special
and really strategically important to us.
So we're going to shout it from the rooftops.
We're going to make a big splash about Google
Play.
Your grandparents are going to know about
it.
Your friends on other platforms are going
to know about it.
And so we're going to continue to do a lot
more in terms of marketing and promotion to
bring more people into the store.
So is that working?
Well, we announced some pretty great numbers
today.
20 billion total app downloads in the store.
1.5 billion apps being downloaded per month
out of 600,000 apps.
So, basically, on any metric that we can measure,
the store is continuing to grow at a very
fast pace.
And the users who are driving that growth
are increasingly global in nature.
So Google Play apps and games are available
in 190 countries and territories.
132 of those support paid applications.
We continue to make investments there, trying
to close that gap and offer paid apps in new
places where we can.
But in terms of the global footprint of Android
users, we have 92% coverage.
So 92% of those folks have access to paid
apps.
And so I think, you know, one of the first
takeaways for you all is just really thinking
about the global opportunity for Android Apps.
In the Google Play store, you want to really
make sure that you're thinking about how to
reach customers in a variety of different
geographies, a variety of different languages,
to really take advantage of the full market
opportunity here.
Now, we talked about an amazing number of
device activations.
But not all devices are alike.
And with the Nexus 7 tablet, what we aspired
to do was to produce a tablet that -- or an
Android device maybe in the more generic sense,
that really sets the goalposts for what a
device that contemplates Google Play at its
core could be.
From the moment you turn on the tablet -- and
I think everyone here is going to be turning
on a tablet pretty darned soon here; right?
So that's pretty awesome.
I had nothing to do with it, but feel free
to applaud.
The -- as soon as you turn it on, you're immediately,
as soon as you come out of the setup wizard,
the very first thing you see is your content
library.
And the other thing that we're doing here
that's pretty novel is, when you activate
the device and create a Wallet account, you're
given $25 in-store credit for the Google Play
store so that you can immediately go in and
start buying things from the store.
And the intention here is to capture people
at that magic moment.
So you know how it is; right?
You get a new device.
You're all amped about it, like, "Oh, this
thing is really cool."
You want to install the latest game on it
to show off your hardware.
You want to trick it out with live wallpaper
and widgets and all that stuff.
So we want to get people right at that magic
moment, give them a direct on ramp to the
store, give them money to spend to create
those sort of habits so that they become a
lifelong user.
I think the other thing that's important here
is that we also preprovision content on this
device.
So when you turn on your device and activate
it, you know, you get a movie to watch.
You get some magazines and a book to read
and things like that, so that you can really
understand what that experience is like, so
that you're -- you know, you understand the
value, you're more willing to make a purchase
when you get into the store.
So a variety of ways that we're bringing customers
to the store and trying to deepen our engagement
with them to keep them coming back and giving
them more reason to come.
The next bit of this, obviously, is revenue,
so monetizing these customers.
And so in terms of revenue, we think of this
in sort of two categories.
So first is thinking about it from the user
point of view.
We want to give users flexible ways to pay.
And then for you as developers, we want to
give you flexible ways to monetize your applications.
From the user point of view, a few things
we've done.
So credit and debit cards clearly continue
to be a very popular way for people to buy
apps.
With the new setup wizard that we've done
in Jelly Bean, we've also made it easy for
users to create a Wallet account and set up
a credit or debit card at that moment when
you're setting up the device and you're in
that mode of, okay, I've got to configure
everything and get everything set up.
So it reduces friction for people purchasing
things in the store afterwards.
Obviously, credit cards aren't popular everywhere
in the world.
So in order to address some other markets,
we've also been aggressively working on carrier
billing as a means to give people a way to
pay.
And then, as I mentioned, the Google Play
Balance is yet another thing that we're rolling
out.
For you as developers, certainly, you know,
a variety of ways to monetize your apps and
ways that are increasing, you know, ad-funded
and paid apps continue to be very popular
and viable ways to monetize your apps.
In-app billing, been a huge success for us.
We'll be talking about that in some greater
detail.
But subscriptions is kind of like -- the way
I think of subscriptions is sort of like the
next wave of in-app billing.
It's an opportunity to create a recurring
revenue relationship with your customers.
Business models.
So you're going to hear this, I'm going to
say this time and time again.
We're going to talk about international.
International markets really is where a lot
of the growth is happening, and international
markets are key to revenue growth.
So fully two-thirds of Google Play revenue
is coming from outside the U.S.
And, now, the United States remains the largest
single country where Android devices are being
activated on a daily basis.
However, in aggregate, there's more devices
being activated outside the U.S. on a daily
basis than inside.
And you can look here.
We've listed some of the top markets for paid
apps.
And even when you just limit this to the top
five, you're already spanning the Americas,
Europe, and Asia.
So really want to be thinking about international
for monetizing your apps.
And I want to start off here and talk a little
bit about an international success story.
So between April of 2011 and April of this
year, revenue in Japan and Korea increased
14X. 14 times.
That's crazy growth.
Now, what happened during that period of time
that accounts for this?
Well, certainly, we activated quite a lot
of Android devices in those regions during
that time.
So that's responsible for some of it.
And certainly there was a lot of, you know,
really compelling apps that were built and
released.
But what really made this happen is this almost
magic combination of direct carrier billing
and in-app billing.
So we're going to talk a little bit about
how that works.
So in Japan and Korea, you know, credit cards
aren't necessarily, you know, the predominant
way that people are used to buying things.
And, you know, actually, I should go further
than that and say that people actually expect
to be able to purchase things using their
phone in these regions.
And so we've really aggressively gone after
carrier billing deployments to enable that.
And we've gotten to a point now where I'm
very happy to say that in Korea and Japan,
full 90% of users are on a mobile network
that offers carrier billing with Google Play.
Now, this isn't, you know, a phenomenon that's
limited to Asia.
Actually, everywhere that we've deployed carrier
billing, Europe and the United States, et
cetera, it's been wildly popular.
It's just such a frictionless way to purchase
things.
It's actually the way that I actually purchase
content myself.
So worldwide, globally, fully 73% of Google
Play app purchases are made with carrier billing
when it's available.
So if it's available to users, they predominantly
choose that as a form of payment.
We've made some pretty significant investments
in carrier billing this year, launched with
a number of new carriers across a number of
countries.
And you can see the list of countries it's
available here.
We're going to continue to really aggressively
push this.
Google Play is the largest Appstore that supports
direct carrier billing.
And we see it as one of the huge growth prospects
for bringing more revenue to the store.
So carrier billing launching in Japan and
Korea.
As part of that success story, every time
we would deploy a new carrier in those regions,
we would see giant jumps in revenue, so there
was this built-up, pent-up demand there that
we were unlocking with each of these launches.
But then the other thing that turned out to
be super popular in these regions was freemium
business model games that leveraged in-app
purchases.
So in-app purchasing has been a huge breakout
success for Google Play, both for developers,
and users have really embraced it as well.
The thing that I really like about in-app
purchasing is, it's one of these things where
it's kind of like a fundamental enabling piece
of infrastructure; right?
So we give you guys this relatively simple
API.
What it allows you to do is to, you know,
make direct charges from within your apps
to users.
But you've taken that and used it in some
incredibly creative ways to figure out a wide
variety of different ways to monetize your
apps.
So, you know, there's the tried and true things,
like, you know, in-app currency or, you know,
collectibles or items in games, or maybe unlocking,
you know, premium features in an application,
et cetera.
But we've also seen some other really creative
things, like people do time-limited offers.
I think one developer did this thing where
you download the free game and, like, within
the first 15 or 30 minutes, like, long enough
that the user understands what the game play
is and probably has a pretty good sense of
what the value of the game is, they offer
them a discount.
Like, you can unlock the game this one time
for a discounted rate.
We've seen a lot of various creative applications
of in-app purchasing.
One specific case study here is from TinyCo.
They implemented our in-app billing API.
And they also did something else that's really
important here, which is timely and kind of
frequent content updates; right?
So you're not only selling things to your
users, but by keeping the content fresh, you
give your users more reason to keep coming
back to your game and more things to purchase,
once again, sort of deepening your engagement
with those users.
They implemented virtual currency in their
app via in-app billing.
And in their own words here from Suli Ali,
the CEO, they said, "Google Play has the highest
average revenue per paying user of all app
stores.
This and other Android metrics make us" -- once
again, their words -- "Android zealots," which
we obviously love to hear.
So that's in-app billing.
That kind of brings us to today.
And so, as I say, the next wave of this is
subscriptions.
So the point I want to get across to you here
is to think broadly about what subscriptions
can mean for you.
It would be kind of easy to fall into a trap
and say, well, subscriptions, that's for,
like, maybe a newspaper or a comic book app
or something where there's some periodic timed
content that's coming through.
But you should really think broadly about
what recurring value you can deliver to users
that they would be willing to pay and engage
in a subscription with you for.
If you think about it this way: Every in-app
conversion you do, right, that's this opportunity
you get where the user has said, okay, I'm
really enjoying this experience.
There's some value here I'm willing to pay
for.
If you could convert that instant into a recurring
revenue opportunity with that user, you're
more deeply engaged with that user, you have,
you know, not only a relationship with them,
but an ongoing revenue stream, that's a very
powerful thing.
So as an example of maybe some, you know,
broad ways to think about subscriptions, one
of our launch partners is Glu.
And they've used subscriptions in an interesting
way.
They implement this thing you can see up here
that's, like, these VIP gold and silver packages.
What that does is it -- it gives you Glu credits
that you can spends in the game and some other
premium features.
But the interesting thing is that it does
that across a portfolio of their games.
So no matter what game you purchase the subscription
for, you get the benefits of that subscription
across a suite of their different games.
And so the cool thing about that is, now you're
kind of building this relationship with a
user where they're kind of invested in your
games; right?
And so maybe they're going to try other games
or other applications that you have where
they might not have otherwise done so.
The CEO of Glu has this to say, that their
subscriptions-based VIP club continues to
grow in popularity as gamers take advantage
of significant bonus value and the easy sign-up
process offered on Google Play.
So think hard about how you can make subscriptions
work for you in creative ways as well.
So the last portion of this segment is optimization.
Optimization is all about getting insight
into your business, understanding, you know,
metrics and analysis so that you have some
sort of hard data to figure out how to optimize
things, and also optimizing delivery and distribution
of your applications.
So the first thing we've done here is, we've
actually put a considerable amount of work
into the Google Play developer console.
We've really -- we've revamped all the statistics
and Analytics and reporting stuff over the
past year.
So you can now get installation data for a
variety of metrics, broken down across a number
of dimensions.
So, for example, you can look at your user
installs and slice and dice it by geography
or carrier or version of the Android platform
that these devices are running, et cetera.
We've got nice, you know, reports and visualization
stuff here in the developer console.
And you can also export the data to use as
you see fit offline.
So that's very useful in terms of, like, analyzing
your acquisition funnel; right?
Figuring out people are getting your games,
how they're downloading it, where they're
coming from, what geographies they're popular
in, might also be kind of a useful early indicator
to figure out what international languages
you should target for localization.
But what about once they're actually in your
application?
Then what happens?
And so Google Analytics is the bit that answers
these questions.
You can integrate with Google Analytics and
answer questions like how frequently are users
running my app?
Are they running it once a week or ten times
a day?
What are they doing when they're inside the
application?
What features are they using or not using?
Or even more interesting, users that end up
performing in-app purchases, what are their
behavior patterns, how did they get to the
in-app purchase completion?
Et cetera.
If you haven't yet integrated with Google
Analytics, you're missing a pretty good opportunity
to get some really detailed insights into
how your application is performing.
If you're interested, they have an SDK for
Android, makes it fairly straightforward to
integrate with.
And there's a deep-dive session that the Analytics
team is running elsewhere at I/O.
So we're also bringing insights and metrics
for some of the other services that surround
Google Play.
So we announced Google Cloud Messaging today.
This is the expansion of the Android cloud
to device message and adds new features and
is now out of beta and complete open and free,
with no quota, for all developers.
And we've integrated statistics and analytics
from Google Cloud Messaging directly into
the Google Play developer console.
So you can see messages about how many metrics
are being sent and once again slice and dice
this across different things like carrier
or, you know, geography, things of this nature.
Now, with all these additional features coming
to the Google Play dev console, chances are
that if you have an organization of any size,
there's probably going to be multiple people
in that organization that want to have access
to it.
So we've added a feature called multiple user
accounts that allows you to invite other people
to view your developer console.
You can also set some access controls to control
who can see the financial and sales information
versus just administer the apps and things
like that: As administrator, you can add and
remove access, et cetera.
The next part gets to distributing your applications.
>>Chris Yerga: With all these additional features
coming to the Google Play def console, chances
are if you have an organization of any size,
there's going to be multiple people in that
organization that want to have access to it.
We added a feature called multiple user accounts
that allows you to invite other people to
view your Google Play developer console.
You can set access controls to control who
can see the financial and sales information
versus just administer the apps, and things
like that, you can, as administrator, you
can add and remove access, et cetera.
Next part gets to distributing your applications,
so we have done a variety of things to help
here.
APK expansion files being one of the more
recent ones.
Prior to APK expansion files, you will remember,
there's a limit of 50 megabytes for an APK
and with increasing screen sizes and pixel
densities, for graphically rich games, it
simply wasn't enough, and so a lot of developers
had to implement their own secondary download
system.
With APK expansion files, we now take care
of that for you.
So you can add up to two gigabyte expansion
files.
We not only host and deliver those files for
you, which means that you don't have to -- you
have to neither invest the engineering resources
to implement that nor incur the cost of hosting
and bandwidth to distribute them, but it also
gives a much more integrated experience for
users.
So we have a case study here from Glu, before
APK expansion file support came to Google
Play, they were losing customers where they
downloaded the APK but hasn't completed the
secondary download.
What that turns into is dissatisfied customers.
Download the app, you want to play, now I
have this secondary download.
With APK expansion files, those customers
are more satisfied and Glu is happy, too,
because we are paying for the downloads and
hosting and they have closed the gap on their
conversion rate to 96% from the previous stats.
The other thing we announced today is smart
app updates.
Pretty simple, right?
Instead of downloading an entire APK, download
a patch file.
We do all the work behind the scenes for you.
You really simply don't have to do anything
except upload an updated version of your APK.
Users download just the changes and on average,
from the analysis we've done, they tend to
be about a third the size of a full app update.
We also heard that you wanted to engage more
deeply with your users.
Reviews is an excellent way to do that.
So we started the rollout of this new feature
called developer replay to review.
Developer reply to review, you will be able
to actually respond to a review in a way that
shows up right there on Google Play and also
you can engage with users that they get an
email notification and it's a great way to
not only kind of close the loop on feedback,
like maybe users having problems, you want
additional information for them, et cetera.
We're initially rolling this out to our top
developer group and we will be expanding this
in the future.
The final thing here is the all new, developer.android.com.
A broader look at what it means to develop
an Android app.
It's beyond engineering.
There's design resources there and we also
talk about distribution and other aspects
of having a successful app business.
Whether you are a brand new developer starting
out and you want to get a jump-start at look
at the free training or maybe even an experienced
developer wanting to learn more about the
newest APIs that are being released, developer.android.com
is the place to go for that.
We put a fair amount of investment into the
Google Play def console over the past year.
We have seen some of the things today.
We feel like we can do a heck of a lot better
with it.
And what I'd like to do now is invite up two
people who have already made it better, Ellie
and Miles are going to give you a demo right
now.
[ Applause ]
>>Ellie Powers: Hi everyone, I'm Ellie Powers.
I'm the product manager for Google app developers
and Google Play.
>>Miles Barr: I'm Miles Barr, interior manager
for Google Play and developers also.
>>Ellie Powers: As Chris mentioned, all of
you Android apps developers have already loaded
600,000 apps into Google Play.
That is astounding.
Thank you for that very much.
Now that your businesses are really growing,
20 billion downloads, you're going to need
a lot better tools to run your businesses
properly.
So we started talking to Android apps developers
everywhere.
Big businesses, small businesses.
We said, tell us, what are your biggest pain
points?
What we heard was basically two major things.
First of all, app publisher in the developer
console was not as smooth as it should be.
Not even close.
And secondly, with a real modern e-commerce
business, you need much, much better tools
that give you not just data about your users
but real insight into your businesses.
So one developer we spoke to said, we use
this site so much, it's so critical to our
business.
Do we use it every day?
Not just that.
We are actually in the tool all day every
day constantly tweaking our offerings.
So with that, we said, we could fix a few
things here and there, make small improvements.
But that wasn't going to work.
No way.
We went completely back to the drawing board
and we said, let's revamp app publishing completely
and let's build a real foundation that can
become the future of what we want to offer
Android apps developers and Google Play to
manage their businesses.
We are happy to announce today that the Google
Play developer console, brand new one, is
in limited beta.
We would love to have you check it out very
soon and let us know what you think.
Your feedback is really crucial to making
sure that it really fits the way your business
runs.
So let's have a look at it.
Miles.
All right, so there it is.
There's really not much to see at first because
we don't have any apps yet.
But you will immediately notice that we have
a brand new look and feel.
It's a lot easier to see where you are in
the site and it's a lot easier to navigate
anywhere that you need to go.
So to show you the brand new app publishing
experience, what would make more sense than
to actually publish a brand new app into Google
Play right now from the stage at I/O. Let's
do that.
Okay.
So we wrote a simple little app.
It's called the Handy Developer Guide, we
are going to publish it today.
One of key things you told us, when you are
publishing a new app, you need to be able
to do it piece by piece.
Sometimes you have the APK but you don't have
the text.
Other times, you might have some of the graphics
ready but not the APK.
Don't worry.
That's not going to be a problem anymore.
You can get started with whatever you have.
[ Applause ]
>>Ellie Powers: Thank you.
We really want to take your feedback.
Seriously, guys.
Okay, so here today we do have an APK on hand.
I wrote it my very self.
It's not the best one, but it's great for
our demo.
So Miles is going to go ahead and upload it.
The developer guide.
There we go.
So once this is done up uploading, we will
be able to review key details of this app.
Things like what API level is it using?
How many languages does it support?
What screen resolutions and so on.
So let's give it a good look to make sure
we have gotten everything right.
I think that looks pretty good.
There's definitely a lot of devices supported,
so I'm happy with that.
Another big piece of feedback that we heard
was, well, this form, it's this big form and
I really can't tell where I am.
Is my app published?
Is it not?
What parts do I still have left to do?
It was confusing, really.
So we tried to fix all that.
At any point you can look in the upper right-hand
corner of the screen.
You can clearly see that this is in a draft
state; it has not been published yet.
If we are not sure what we still need to do,
we can click there at any time and it will
give us a list of this is what you need to
do to publish your app.
We can see from the check mark that this APK
is totally fine, we're all set.
It's time to move on to the store listing.
Okay.
So Miles is going to enter the description
of this little app.
It doesn't do very much, so it shouldn't take
him too long.
One important thing that Chris mentioned is
all of the international growth.
It is huge.
It is really astounding.
It's really a priority to make sure that each
one of your businesses no matter where in
the world you are based that you are able
to reach users all over the world.
Users who speak many different languages,
users you have never met before, your business
should be able to expand to them.
Two-thirds of the revenue is outside the country
of the U.S. and your businesses should be
as well.
So we recently just launched the Play store
on the web no an additional 22 languages.
You may recognize many of them.
Everything from UK English all the way down
to, you know, other ones like -- what else
did we launch.
I think we launched Zulu.
So for our little demo today, we will add
Korean.
Chris made a great case study for that 14X
growth.
Miles is going to go ahead and add a translation
in Korean.
Okay.
Let's put Handy Developer Guide in Korean.
>>Miles Barr: One problem, I don't speak Korean.
>>Ellie Powers: Me neither.
What should we do?
>>Miles Barr: Let's get rid of Korean and
rely on the auto translate feature.
>>Ellie Powers: That's a great idea.
One of the thing we heard from users is, I
may not speak a language where a certain developer
has provided human translation already but
I still want to learn with that app.
With Google, we have Google translate, how
can we put that work for you and your users?
What will happen will automatic translations
a user who goes to the play store will be
able to see either the original language that
you've provided or an automated translation
in their native language.
And to keep this updated properly, you don't
have to do anything at all.
The automated translates updates any time
you update your translation.
Okay.
So until Miles or I finish our Korean lessons,
we will let automated translation do its job.
Let's move on to the fun part.
Screen shots.
We will do the minimum.
Two screen shots of the app, and this is really
not the best practice.
Yes.
As you can see here we have a great graphic
designer who has made us fantastic graphics
to promote the app.
Now, if this were a real app that we would
have great success on, we need to do a couple
things.
We could have a screen shot of the app running
on the new Nexus 7 tablet.
That would be fantastics, especially if it
has tablet-specific features.
A user can see, yes, if I download this on
to my tablet, if I install it, maybe I'm willing
to pay even a little bit more because I know
that the tablet version is going to be so
great.
Another real important thing I want to mention
here is the feature graphic.
So when you make your store listing on the
web, the main center point of it is the feature
graphic.
It's the big banner that users see when they
go there.
You definitely want to have it there.
If our editorial team is looking to feature
your app, a feature graphic is absolutely
a must have.
So okay, Miles, are we all set there?
Okay, one more thing that a lot of top developers
mention to us, they said, okay, how do I take
my lesson to the next level of professionalism.
I actually need a video.
Especially if you're working on a really novel
app that doing something interesting and different.
Nothing like a video explains to a users,
hey, when you get the app on your phone, do
this, here's why it's cool, here's how you
use it, it's really fun, definitely recommend
your video there as well.
So it's pretty clear at this point that one
of the key things is the better that you can
communicate with your users about the value
of your app, the better off you're going to
be.
So along that theme, earlier this year we
introduced privacy policy URLs.
So for the past couple months, you have been
able to go into the developer console and
enter a privacy policy URL for each app you
have should you wish to do so.
As of today, users browsing Google Play, the
privacy policy URLs will be visible.
This is a great way to evaluate your apps
in Google Play.
Looks like we are at the bottom of the page.
We will scroll up.
We are going to save.
Okay.
So our last step is going to be pricing and
distribution.
This is a simple app.
We are going to make it available for free.
I wouldn't pay for it.
Distribute it everywhere.
We are also going to agree to the policies.
Definitely have a look through these if you
haven't done so recently just to make sure
that you are aware of how the rules go.
Okay, how are we doing?
Wow, ready to publish.
That's cool.
>>Miles Barr: Let's publish this.
>>Ellie Powers: Okay.
We will do it.
So this is a real thing happening.
We are actually sending our app off into the
Google Play store.
After we do this, you will really be able
to download your app on your very own phone
and tablet, try it out, have a look, and there
we go.
>>Miles Barr: Actually, Ellie, I think I uploaded
the wrong APK.
>>Ellie Powers: Are you serious?
Come on, we are on stage.
All right, are we going to fix this?
>>Miles Barr: Let's upload the proper version.
>>Ellie Powers: So Miles is going to upload
this new version.
All right.
Let's have a look.
We are actually going to see the cool comparison
right now.
>>Miles Barr: Hang on, 23 devices have been
removed.
>>Ellie Powers: Why is that?
That's not good.
>>Miles Barr: Bluetooth?
Why does a set of links need Bluetooth.
>>Ellie Powers: I must have pasted that into
the wrong app when I was updating my app this
morning.
This app is a obviously bad version.
>>Miles Barr: Let's get rid of it then.
>>Ellie Powers: We have heard from developers
that that has happened, with the new comparisons
tool, we will make sure that you never do
an oopsy update again.
Here we go, we have published our app, waiting
it to show up in the store, let's look at
some stats from an existing app that we have.
So a lot of you said that the current developer
console is too slow.
Does anyone have a lot of apps?
A hundred or maybe a thousand or ten thousand.
It gets really slow.
With the new search box, you can jump exactly
to the one that you want and the whole site
runs a lot faster.
As Chris mentioned, we update the statistics
this year.
You can see a lot of great data about your
user installs, upgrades, everything likes
that.
You can break it down by these six dimensions,
export it, do more analysis.
It's really handy.
So most of you are probably familiar with
this already.
Okay, let's have a look at the reviews.
Here's what it looks like in the new site.
Earlier this year we introduced the ability
to see your app version, your device and the
language from each of the reviews that users
are leaving.
I like to use this all the time to understand
who are these people giving me one star?
What do they have in common and how can I
try to make them a bit happier.
Okay.
And if Miles and I were top developers, which
we are not, we would be able to reply to users
reviews.
We want to roll that out to more developers
in the future, as well.
All right, so that's it.
That's the new developer console.
[ Applause ]
>>Ellie Powers: We've had a fantastic team
of designers, engineers, testers, localization
people, everyone working together to really
bring this to you to make it a core part of
your business.
We are really going to love to hear your feedback
as soon as possible.
Soon we will be recruiting for more developers
to try it out, be among the first to see it.
If you'd like to be in the next group, we
will be soon making a link available in the
developer console where you will be able to
sign up.
Please do check it out.
Let us know what you think, and we really
do care.
Thank you so much for all you've done to make
Google Play great and we really look forward
to bringing you even more over the next year.
Thank you.
>>Miles Barr: Thank you everyone.
Back to you, Chris.
>>Chris Yerga: Thank you Ellie and Miles.
So I want to do one other brief demo here
for you.
So just over a year ago we launched the web
version of then Android Market now Google
Play and one of the novel features we had
at that time was this -- the ability to purchase
an app directly from the web site and have
it install directly to your device.
Since that time when we pulled all the content
together on Google Play, we have added the
section at the top where you can get to your
library so you can see all your music and
your books and now your magazines and TV as
well.
As part of that, we've also revamped the way
that you can go in and take a look at all
of your Android apps that are installed across
the variety of devices.
And that last point is actually very important
because Android is now getting to a point
where users are more frequently have multiple
devices.
They might have a phone and a tablet or multiple
phones, et cetera.
And so now with the new my applications section
here, you can actually go across and look
at the apps that have been installed on a
variety of your devices and you also get a
view into the apps that are in your library
that haven't yet been installed.
Think about the scenario where a user has
purchased one of your applications, gets a
second device right, there's that kind of
awkward period where you've got to -- I have
to install the apps and go through and figure
out what things I like.
It's really easy, particularly for someone
like me who has been on Android for quite
a while and has amassed quite a number of
apps in their library, to quickly go through
here and install those apps to their new devices.
You can also delete applications from your
device and we think it's a great way for users
to basically get all of their app story pulled
together through the power of the Cloud much
like the rest of our content.
If we could switch back to the slides now.
We're going to take things out here with five
top tips for 2012.
So things that I would recommend that you
spend energy on if you haven't yet.
And the first thing we want to start with
is this notion of focus on the user.
Usability, design, user feedback.
At the end of the day, obviously, the -- you
know, the goal here is delight your users
and have them have an excellent product experience.
And I think users' expectations for Mobile
applications have gotten fairly high, right?
I mean, as everybody is sort of raising their
game in terms of user experience and app development.
And so I think there's a couple things that
are worthy to mention here.
The first is really making benefit of user
reviews.
You want to aim to have a great app with great
design, great usability that users are going
to rate highly for a couple reasons.
One is high ratings in the Google Play store
is every racer who rates your app highly is
promoting your application to others who come
through the store and it's an opportunity
for you to close those conversions.
Also reviews are a great way to get feedback
about issues you might be having in your applications.
I wanted to talk a little bit about what we
mean when we say focus on the user from a
case study here from this app called Pocket.
Pocket's a cool app that lets you basically
clip content from the web or videos or blogs
or things like that and all bring them together
in a single, unified reading experience.
And what Pocket did is they've built their
application from the ground up on Android.
So they make use of the Android framework
owes share intent so that you can add share
intent to the Pocket application from all
of other Android apps, they also use a cloud-to-device
messaging and you can clip from the web and
send a notification to the Pocket web running
on the Android device, basically everything
to have that sort of unique Android experience.
And I think when they first started off and
this is probably true for a number of developers
early on it wasn't really apparent like what
the best practices for Android apps should
look like.
Now with the release of our Android UX guidelines
and design guidelines, we make that much easier.
So I'd encourage you to take a look at the
UX and design guidelines and there's a few
other things you could consider doing here.
Do beta tests.
Reach out to users, maybe have a usability
study of your application.
Think hard about all the things you can do
to deliver a compelling experience to your
users.
so the next thing, obviously, we've been talking
a lot about is localization.
Think about what are the different regions
that I want to take my app to and think about
the global marketplace that's available there
and how you can reach it.
Maybe you start with just localizing your
Google Play store listing or maybe eventually
engage with a professional translation firm
or take advantage of the auto translation
feature that we heard about.
Now, localization is -- takes many forms.
One case study we want to talk about here
is Foursquare.
So Foursquare, as you know, it's a local app
where people can check in at various venues,
et cetera, and one thing that they noticed
is that they started to have growth outside
of the U.S. in an interesting way.
They had users that were actually helping
to build out their location database for them
predominantly started with native English-speakers
who were abroad, but by building out their
location database for them, these users were
really helping them grow and provide a compelling
experience to users outside of the U.S.
So they invent advised that by giving batchers
to these super users to encourage this behavior.
They did anales to the places where the greatest
amount of activity was happening and then
they then localized their application into
a dozen languages to target those different
markets.
And the result of that is now fully 50% of
their user base is now outside of the U.S.
So that's a way for you to think about ways
to sort of get your app available into different
markets.
the third thing to tab here is making your
app look great on tablets, a lot of Android
tablets are going to be sold this year particularly
around the holiday season and we think that
we've just released a killer one with the
Nexus 7.
So, you know, tablet users don't just want
an exploded-up version of a phone application
so think about how you can make your applications
tablet-optimized and deliver a really compelling
experience on tablets.
A case study I want to get in here is from
mint.com who I think really did an excellent
job of this.
So what Mint does -- they use the Android
fragments APIs fairly -- fairly extensively,
they have an application that adapts itself
dynamically to phones and tablets, they've
done, actually both seven-inch and 10-inch
optimized versions of their application on
tablets.
And using the fragments API it actually -- adapting
their 10-inch tablet layout to support seven-inch
tablets, something they got done in under
a week.
The other thing they noticed, however, is
that the usage patterns of their applications
varied significantly between phones and tablets.
So what Mint saw is that on phones they would
see kind of peak usage around midday, maybe
around lunchtime or something like that but
the duration of those sessions were fairly
short.
People would make just go in and check their
bills or check their balances or something
like that but tablet users would peak much
later in the day, in the evening time or after
dinner, and those sessions lasted much longer
and those users were much more engaged with
their devices.
And so the way Mint put that information to
use for them is in their tablet versions of
their applications they actually added new
features there that aren't present on the
phone to enable users to engage with their
budget and do more things in the mode where
they're kind of willing to more deeply engage
there.
So the other thing that you could do here
is actually Mint added tablet screen shots
to the play store to promote the fact that
they have this sort of premium experience
on tablets.
So think hard about how to reach tablet users
and the things that you can do to deliver
and experience to them that really leverages,
you know, the capabilities of their device
rather than giving them just a translated
phone experience.
number four here is revenue model.
You know, think creatively and figure out
what's the best revenue model for my application.
As we've talked about a couple times here,
there's a variety of different models here.
You know, if you look at the sort of top grossing
charts in the Google Play store, a lot of
those apps are Freemium apps, right, free
apps that sell in-app purchases, but not all
of them are.
So, you know, there's no sort of one-size-fits-all
model for success.
So maybe if you haven't considered this in
a while, it's time to think if there's a different
way to monetize your apps.
An example here is from the folks at Cellfish
C-E-L-L-fish, see what they did there?
And they sell these live wallpapers and they
license things from movies and sports teams
and things like that.
And when they started out, they had a paid
app version of their live wallpaper that they
sold, but they decided to try a different
tack and so what they did is they offered
a free version of their app that only offered
some sort of generic NFL branding and then,
from within the application they enabled people
to purchase, you know, custom versions for
their favorite sports teams and things like
that.
They also went a step further and they offered
packages.
So you could maybe get the live wallpaper
as well as a ring tone or theme or something
else as a bundle.
It's like, well, just another dollar more
for the upsell and you get this package deal
and they've had great success with this model.
The other thing that they did which is something
that we've mentioned earlier as well is keeping
their content fresh.
So they've done like seasonal customizations,
you know, around the holiday times and things
like that.
And when the Giants won the Super Bowl, they
actually had confetti flying in the live wallpaper
just a few minutes after the end of the game
So, you know, think about how inapp or something
like subscriptions work for your application
and figure out if there's some creative ways
you could reconsider your business models
if you haven't really given that a look in
a while
so the final thing we want to talk about today
in terms of our tips is investing in analytics
and marketing.
We talked a lot about, you know, Google analytics
and the insight it gives you and once you've
made the investment to build a really compelling
application experience, you know, you want
to like tell the world about it.
You want to invest in marketing and promotion
to get it out there.
And you can think creatively there's a variety
of different ways to do that.
So I want to talk here about a case study
with Smule, so their marketing is not terribly
traditional.
They make these really cool apps like Magic
Piano and Songify that use your phone in creative
ways that are musical in nature.
So because their apps are so musical, video
is a really effective way for them to get
their point across.
And so it turns out that, you know, they get
a lot of engagement from video ads as well
as YouTube channels.
They partnered with some of these YouTube
superstars to focus on use either their products
in their videos or do videos about using their
products and they found some interesting thing,
when they combined that marketing and promotion
with analytics, what they saw was that users
who inquired the app through this Jimmy Wong
video on YouTube, once they actually had the
app were twice as engaged with the app and
used it a lot more than a other users.
And when they took a look at this, they found
that the reason was that in the video, it
was actually very good at explaining how to
use the application and so they got a whole
'nother level of insight there on not only
how am I doing a conversion, how am I getting
a customer to acquire my application, but
how am I also using these channels to get
customers who are more engaged with my app
and actually have a better understanding of
the value that they're getting as well.
In summary, focus on the user, localize your
apps, make it look great on tablets, find
your revenue model, use any of the variety
of ways to monetize your app and make sure
that you invest in analytics and marketing.
Before we close out today, I want to give
a little bit of a shout out to some other
sessions that are coming up.
We only had a little bit of time here so we
weren't able to really deep dive into some
of these topics but there will be there's
going to be folks here in this very same room
coming up next that are going to do that.
I believe the next session is going to deep
dive on Android app monetization and then
there's going to be a session on marketing
and promoting your apps in Google Play.
So with that, I started with a thank you,
I'll end with a thank you.
Thank you very much for your attention and
your very hard work.
[ Applause ]